[Applaudissements]
avec ça va c'est lutter elle dure
lachute saint légumes arrivés à jour un
truc en bateau sans déconner j'étais
avec un je suis en vacances avec un mec
et il a un bateau et le gard voilà il
est comme un ouf pour qu'on aille sur
son bateau il dit vraiment le gabon
hyper riches et marc du riz et il nous
dit dans un mec qui m'a invité sur son
bateau forcément donc voilà et donc un
mec qui me dit bon davin bateau et donc
j'arrive sur la tête de ma mère et je
suis je suis comme as et j'avais une
crème solaire
vous savez la crème solaire qui est tout
noir vous savez les on va pour ne pas la
nommer
c'est je crois que c'est une crème voilà
je sais pas qui reste et je crois que
c'est lancaster on veut nommer d'autres
valérie bénaïm biotherm l'envié mais on
est donc et elle est vraiment très très
noir et sur la tête de ma mère et il
avait jour du texte sur le bateau et le
mec il est comme un ouf sur son bateau
mais genre voilà et mon bateau tu as vu
mon bateau oui oui on a vu le bateau bah
c'est bon et donc je m'assois et sans
rigoler et je m'assois sur la crème
haïti écoute moi bien mais là il y avait
une banquette mais page fracasse la
banque et et derrière je veux essuyé mon
frère et j'essaie d'essuyer lui les
devants en train de conduire
il entend par là mon frère et la
banquette mais je la fracasse et après
on faire il avait du tech
le truc je vous jure que c'est vrai que
c'était moi le gars le plus malchanceux
à la crème elle tombe sur le texte au
nil partout sur le tech et je veux
essuyer avec une serviette et je suis
comme ça pendant que le mec il est comme
ça là bas ça la mer et je veux pas
qu'ils se retournent le gars au 3 mai
écoute moi bien
j'ai mis un sac j'ai mis une serviette
et le mec est un moment s'arrête ni tu
veux pas de béni un peu non
[Rires]
la somavie bannu à la fin qu'est ce que
j'ai fait on est arrivé à quai et j'ai
dit je vais te tape à un tuyau pour
qu'ils nettoient un peu et donc j'ai
nettoyé avec de l'eau et avec l'eau donc
c'était noir sur noir est arrivé et je
me suis sauvé le gâche les plus jamais
revu une valise pagaie son bateau j'ai
plus jamais répondu à ses appels
3 j'avais une angoisse dans le bateau
sur ma vie j'avais attrapé des coups de
soleil par toutes les radios
voilà donc le gars m'a jamais appelé
voilà